this is mind-blowing to me because this
movie doesn't come out for
another week and they're just straight
up spoiling this movie publicly this is
insane
[Music]
what is happening there reject nations
so we are putting this up on saturday
leave a like by the way i forgot to
mention that we're putting this up on
saturday we were showing this on friday
a little bit after we did our last
morbius video we did not intend for this
to be morbius week and weird morbius
newsweek but apparently the morbius
director this is approved by sony did an
interview with cinema blend and just
straight up spoiled some big stuff about
the film answered some questions
clarified some things about spider-man
all i got was that information i don't
know the actual details or what the
specific answers are i was just like i
can't believe he actually did that so
there's going to be spoilers in here
that's all i know is going to be
spoilers first question from cinema
blend what universe does morbius take
place in daniel espinoza apparently
answered morbius lives in the same
universe as venom this is the universe
we saw venom exit at the end of venom
let there be carnage and returned to at
the end of spider-man no way home okay
that clarifies something because can't
believe we're getting these answers
because before we were being told that
maybe morbius just takes place in its
own separate universe even outside of
venom so at least this puts it in
conjunction with that which could
coordinate to the mcu in the tom holland
verse based off of the post-credits
scene from phenomenal garbage but it
still doesn't explain the tobey maguire
spider-man suit and it doesn't explain
the andrew garfield oscorp logo so which
spider-man universe does it take place
in exactly the venom belongs in as well
now second question is there a
spider-man in venom's universe to which
daniel espinosa replies
of course very descriptive they go on to
ask okay so which spider-man exists in
venom's universe daniel espinoza
responds it is my understanding that
audiences will discover the answer soon
okay so at least we'll get some answers
at some point
not going to be answered in this movie
apparently all right let's shift to
michael keaton who we saw in your
morbius trailers is he playing the same
adrian tombs vulture from spider-man
homecoming
yes
what
i like that the point of this is to
clarify things and i'm i'm starting to
get more confused again how did he get
to venom and morbius's universe well at
the end of venom let there be carnage
and spiderman no way home and in no way
home itself it is clearly established
that it is possible for characters to
transfer from one multiverse to another
the events of no way home had the effect
of transferring venom and vulture and
maybe others back and forth between the
mcu and the venom universe okay so it's
it's made quitter then of how this all
works i guess so at least in a in a
singular kind of way it doesn't seem
like they can just hop back and forth
whenever they please but yeah okay so no
this just straight up spoils and exactly
how adrian toombs is there then so after
the events of no way home adrian tombs
was just planted over there in in the
morbius world which is the venom world i
guess so that's what i'm taking from
this and he just adjusted and he was
just like
a lot of strange things happening i got
a vulture suit now i'm in a new universe
whatever it's tuesday this is
mind-blowing to me because this movie
doesn't come out for
another week and they're just straight
up spoiling this movie publicly this is
insane that's a fascinating marketing
approach how did adrian tombs get his
vulture suit at the end of morbius i
just learned something brand spanking
new if you look closely you will see it
is not quite the same suit as homecoming
he is a resourceful guy
[Laughter]
just hit the ground running right when
he landed in this universe did adrian
assumes his family not come with him
does he not give a [ __ ] about him
reuniting with his daughter liz whatever
his wife's name is he doesn't care about
any of that he's like no i'm gonna just
plant my mark here's fresh start
starting here unless in the venom
universe this is a fresh start here
literal get out of jail free card last
question is vulture and morbius setting
up a sinister six movie
well he is recruiting teammates and he
has enticed one already so it sure looks
like a start well there you go there's
the spoiler for you that they're
actually going to be setting up a
sinister six movie via through adrian
tombs and apparently adrian toombs is
going to be the leader of the sinister
sex and vulture will be sure i i guess
that's wrong with that i mean he doesn't
seem like he has the biggest motivation
to be like a kingpin of of you know
multiversal criminals but then again who
knows maybe he's become harder even in
prison okay so what have we learned
venom and morbius are in the same
universe adrian toomes gets his suit at
the end he's a resourceful guy somehow
through the events of no way home he was
transferred over to this universe and he
has decided to just roll with the
punches and stay here and start
recruiting a sinister six while he's on
this version of work i might as well
double down on where i left off on the
last earth no fresh start in a whole new
life as just a good guy or whatever but
no yeah gotta wreak some habit if i'm
remembering correctly in spider-man
homecoming adrian tombs he builds his
suit via chatari technology i don't know
exactly how he he built
any of this stuff but these are all the
things that people would be most
interested in probably learning i'm not
saying everybody i know there's a lot of
people out there who just want to see a
morbius movie and see morbius adapted
and really get the gist of that but this
is uh this is like the big these are the
cliffhanger pieces of information the
things to most look forward to
after morpheus and he just straight up
just let them all out of the bag this
time around why give it a surprise
adrian tube's probably gonna break into
oz corp now there you go there's some
technology there i wonder if this was
part of like sony pr being like you
gotta clarify some stuff because the
leaks got out spider-man connections are
not in this movie remove stuff from the
trailer and we need to keep people
excited about this so can you start
talking about how this does tie into
spider-man it is building the bigger
spider-man universe can you clean up our
mess please because yeah he's got to
have like a publicist or a pr team
nearby to be like you can't be answering
that you can't be saying that he's a
director of the movie yeah so they have
to be on like on watch when it comes to
these certain things because i'm
surprised by how much he just straight
up spoiled it's weird how in the last
like two weeks before this movie is
getting released how it's had the
strangest press when you look at no way
home how just everything was getting
spoiled likes most of it just was
getting leaked and put out there the
trailers had to do a better job at not
revealing stuff and hiding stuff and
digitally removing things and now you
look at morbius everything was fine
other than the weird situations it ran
into which was through no fault of its
own i'm assuming getting the release
dates pushed back due to the pandemic
but then some rumors about reshoots and
stuff and things they maybe wanted to
add in now it seems like they just
wanted to re-edit and take stuff out and
then to now put all this information out
there upon things getting revealed about
no spider-man connections it's just a
bizarre couple weeks leading into this
movie that has been promoted for a few
years at this point i don't know how to
feel about any of these places this is
like they've just given up i guess well
yeah it's a weird turn from the studio
who was like we don't even want to show
the returning villains and the no way
home trailers but i guess we have to and
we'll keep some stuff a secret and now
this seems like the complete opposite of
that after they already invited it upon
themselves by putting in all these
potential crossovers from other
universes in the advertising like i
wonder if somebody went let's try a new
approach let's mislead everybody oh wait
that really backfired okay we just got
to tell them the truth yeah
before people sue us maybe for false
advertising all right guys well what do
you think about this morbius information
we learned quite a bit here yet it
doesn't spoil the actual movie isn't
that ironic
leave your thoughts down below subscribe
keep a lookout for a morbius review